you know receptions I think it's that
way not really sure exactly where yeah
we gave through those tools there yeah
reflections you are the individual's
personality yeah Natalie been Mosby from
part 95.5 host of the team bridge sports
personality of the year awards I'm
really really sorry about all this I
wasn't going to do this but they told me
I needed to go deep undercover to kind
of get you here and surprise you so
first of all I suppose the first
question is how do you feel and yeah
mazing obviously it's um it's cool to
have such an unusual sport recognized I
guess and it's an amazing award to be to
be part of and even just to be nominated
for really OC team was you've been
really supportive of all of my amateu
even say thank you very much I know
you've had an amazing year delis got to
be one of the things we've got to talk
about but other than that what else have
you achieved is here is great but a lot
isn't it it has yeah it's been a really
busy here am I actually wonder England
lady singles which was and probably well
obviously before Delhi was a highlight
of my year and I was also part of the
world cup team which is the top eight in
the county and we play obviously all the
other counties and we won that one as
well this year so that was really nice
to be a part of a team and you know sort
of win it with other people as well
sorta singles is quite literally say and
bowls as a whole I mean I might get told
off for saying this but you kind of
think of it more as kind of an old
person sport I know it's getting the
reputation now a lot of young people are
getting involved what made you want to
get into the sport when you were younger
and it's very much a sore family day
sport I think you don't find young
people who play that haven't got some
sort of family connection and my dad
actually plays so that's how I go into
it and start when I was nine so I
shouldn't plan for 12 years now which is
quite a long time but I'm know I really
enjoy it and it's just one of those
sports where people need to give it a
chance and it's really competitive like
everything else and it's taken me around
the world so I can't complain at all and
obviously you're still you're still
studying aren't you you got to do a lot
of training obviously with the bottles
how do you kind of fit everything into
you your daily life and
was really tough my first two years of
uni I did play balls as well but I've
actually taken this indoor season off so
I can concentrate on my studies it's my
last year and say you know I really
wanted to sort of get my degree sorted
and then that can be my plan B if stuff
with balls doesn't work out really and
someone like yous got to be an
aspiration to younger people to come on
and try a sport like bowls and what
would you say to the people who perhaps
have never thought about giving it a try
and definitely just give it a chance in
it and for a kid to you don't
necessarily like playing football or
hockey you know Bowles is such a great
alternative gives you a chance to be
part of a team and teaches you sort of
etiquette and sportsmanship and it's
such a massive part of growing up and
you know I wouldn't I wouldn't be so the
person I am today if I didn't have a
sport in my life and it's just been
great to sort of grow up with with grey
and sport really I think everyone should
should have at least a hobby they should
talk be able to get away from their
normal life and just you know sort of
participate in something like that or
Natalie many congratulations I'm really
really sorry about this again I'm really
sorry they told me to do it this look
here but set well done and thoroughly
deserve congratulations thank you very
much thank you